c'est bien sur le répondeur de patrick
fiori ce message
vous aurez mon message vous réveillant
je vécu des années magnifiques avec marc
[Musique]
on amène au travail faire naître une
agricultrice moderne comme actif
dans ma région comme un coup les gens
meurent en silence
je voudrais juste que vous fassiez
entendre mais moi j'ai la chance
d'être à zip une substance absolument
inoffensif selon son fabricant mégueule
oms a classé comme cancérogène ça fait
trois quatre ans que leurs lobbys font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour détruire
tous les programmes de santé publique
l'homme
l'atrazine et le désherbant le plus sûr
jamais produit le meilleur merci
le sait et personne ne dit rien et nous
[ __ ] cultivés sans pesticides se
traduirait par la disparition de plus de
30% des volumes produits il faut vous
battiez
tu ressentes est en danger nos enfants
sont en danger certains le savent et
nous mentent
132 l'ampleur jeunes face à jean
monsieur je peux vous appeler patrick
plus - m on a pris connaissance de vos
difficultés financières on peut sortir
de ce dossier par une transaction
le site orange la défense coupe
admirent votre détermination fait très
attention
les gens sont perdus une pomme notre
métier c'est de les rassurer
veut croire qu'il est à un autre monde
possible plus honnête et plus ou moins
alors je vous pose la question parce que
les bourreaux gagne toujours face à
leurs victimes